I just landed in the capsule Bangkok and
I'm straight off the plane and ready for
my first taste of Thailand
[Music]
that's food everywhere
every into these patients
food after food after food after food
Tai is Britain's fastest growing cruzi
and I can't wait to get to grips with it
now I know how to make a pad thai but
that's about the extent of my Thai
cuisine repertoire
there's better than just pad thai here
I've got my work cut out just one week
to master authentic Thai food
so I've asked one of Thailand's top
chefs to help me on my way now there's
one unique individual who's chef but
dang and I found this guy's clucked at
more primetime hours than me this guy's
gonna set me on the right track I can't
wait to get started
I've agreed to meet celebrity chef Matt
dang for dinner
first off Ryan enter market between
squids fast oh look at a place not at a
fancy restaurant he asked me to meet him
at his favorite street food stall in
Bangkok to educate me in authentic Thai
cooking know he's given me a map but
it's a foreign language to me but I know
a star when I see one your mile away how
are you good to see you to meet you how
are you very 1d player so excited to be
here this place is basically amazing
amazing and it's this is one of my
favorite star hello
okay this is mr. whiskers mr. whiskers
right and the most popular dish would be
pad thai no no oh Jesus crazy okay why
not that's really boring is this yeah
because every Westerner says Oh Thai
food pad thai okay Paul why don't you
try something that we consider that like
the Thai hamburger a one plate dish that
we always eat okay oh you saw parka
power okay pal take me through please
so chicken donor and he puts the chicken
in there cooking the Thai wing looks
simple but there are strict principles I
need to master give me the secret behind
good Thai cuisine it's a balance of
taste nice saltiness and sound but you
cannot cook Thai food without a pit
without pace saltiness sweetness
sourness in a paste is the bedrock of
Thai food with different ingredients
used to deliver the essential flavors
and then the sauce for sweetness in it
I'm boys that that's the business the
holy the holy basil amazing I mean it
smells incredible there you go thank you
can I do this break that you just stuck
yeah a crispy fried on top on top of my
delicious pugna pile why you find an egg
on top of this amazing food Wow I know
but this is how we eat it combines all
the flavors delicious it works